تتصاعد وتيره المعارك في اوكرانيا ويتصاعد
معها الحديث عن حجم الامدادات الغربيه
القادمه لكيف لكن القتال في مدينه سوليدار
شماليه دونيت بات العنوان الابرز لاعن في
حروب القنادق منذ غزو روسيا لاوكرانيا
تقول نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني على
تليجرام ان عددا كبيرا من وحدات مجموعه
فاجنر تهاجم المدينه مستخدمه تكتيكات
جديده والمزيد من الجنود تحت غطاء من
المدفعجيه الثقيله
وانظمه راجمه صواريخ وقضائها
على جبهات القتال وفي المقابل تحجم من
الدعوات الغربيه
حيث قررت برلين تزويد الجيش الاوكراني
بعربته للمساعده في سد القوه الروسيه
وتعاهدت الولايات المتحده بتزويد كيف
بعربات للقتاليه اما فرنسا سترسل قتاليه
خفيفه من طراز اي ام اكس 10 ار سي فيما
تدرس بريطانيا ارسال دبابات قتاليه من
طراز تشالنج 2
لقد قررت ايضا مع الرئيس الامريكي
ورئيس الوزراء البريطانيه
صواريخ المتعدده واسلحه ثقيله جدا لدعم
الدفاع عن اوكرانيا
امام الوعد الغربي تبرق روسيا رسائلها على
رؤوس صواريخ اسكندر هذه الاروع الناريه
التي تسمح للقوات الروسيه بملامسه الاهداف
الاوكرانيه وتدمير بنيتها التحتيه
العسكريه